if you lived in a world full of
horrifying demons what would you do
you've just been given terrifying
chainsaw powers from hell and every
demon in the world will now try to hunt
you down and kill you I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the hell monsters in
chainsaw man this kid is going to die
and come back to life as a horrifying
demon denji here is in big trouble his
dad has just died and he also owes money
to the Yakuza not having anyone else
denji is forced to take on his father's
debt getting a job as an illegal bounty
hunter that hunts horrifying monsters he
becomes a Demon Hunter he gets up one
day to go to work along with his pet
demon called pochita and these two get
together to take out this monster and
denji uses pochita as a chainsaw after
he barely gets enough money due to all
the debt that his father owes to pressed
all denji wants is to be free from this
life and to finally get a girlfriend oh
that's so sad reaching home he realizes
that he doesn't have enough money for
peanut butter and jam and him share one
piece of sad toast before bed but that's
when he gets a knock on his door it's
the boss of the Yakuza and they have
another job for him they drive him to
the super Shady warehouse but deji
doesn't see no demon in sight it's
strange and he begins to think that
something is up the old man then stops
and reveals to denji the best news for
the Yakuza he tells denji that there's
been a change of plans he now needs to
die don't you think gets stabbed in the
back and collapses confused as hell a
devil that comes out of the Shadows
known as a zombie devil it reveals to
denji that all the yakuza's minds are
now being controlled by this devil and
it has turned all of them into
horrifying willing zombie prisoners
turns out selling your soul for power is
a very popular thing among criminals
badly injured Genji tries to escape but
the zombies catch him and stab him to
death that's it well that's a short
season okay denji here is in a world
full of basically in this world
people's fears can turn into Devils if
gun seems scary to you there's probably
a gun devil out there somewhere scared
of knives there's a knife devil too
Jokes Aside these real Devils can
possess dead bodies and can make deals
with humans via a sacrifice of some kind
and right now Genji being led into this
situation is entirely his fault the year
is 1997 which means that Japan's money
lending problem during this time period
would have been a huge problem police
aren't enforcing the laws and Japan
right now is a heaven on Earth for loan
sharks and did you all know an estimated
25 of these loan sharks have ties to the
Yakuza denji's father owed about 278
thousand dollars that's a large amount
let's make it worse in 2023 it would
come to the tune of five hundred and
eighteen thousand one hundred and eighty
eight dollars oh that's a lot of money
and now we have to pay it back since our
daddy is dead and he just made our lives
way more hard but one thing that we
should have noticed way sooner was the
fact that we're never going to be able
to pay the Yakuza back anyways thanks to
something called High compound interest
that is when you pay a monthly fee for
borrowing money so whatever amount we
owed to the Yakuza each month that we
failed to pay them back they tax us
additional money on top of it as a
consequence my father's loan was likely
not super high to begin with but because
of this the amount that we now owe has
gone over 10 times the original and this
would keep happening and not stop we
should have started planning for ways to
escape long ago and one very easy method
that we could have done would have been
to run away but instead he chose to be
clueless until the very end and proved
to be useless as a man like father like
son I guess denji's corpse and a now
very dead pochetta are thrown into the
trash and blood spills from denji into
his demon dog's mouth bringing it back
to life it then quickly uses its powers
to enter denji's mind and offers his
soul a deal it will give its demon heart
to denji if he promises to live a better
life from now on and show pochita
denji's dream denji agrees and wakes up
Suddenly all healed and good as new but
something has changed he then notices a
string hanging from his chest and now
realizes that he has the powers of his
dog the zombie devil then sees denji
alive and orders his zombie army to
attack him then she quickly pulls his
string on his chest but nothing happens
and he quickly gets overrun the zombie
devil thinks it's over but that's when
he hears a rumbling motor sound and it
gets loud tenji then bursts out
transformed into chainsaw man oh frick
yeah let's cut up some zombies sorry got
a little excited moving on he starts
brutally cutting up all of these zombies
he quickly reaches the zombie devil and
cuts him in half slicing through this
bad guy's brain and killing him dead his
devil side taking over this kid quickly
loses control and goes full-on psycho
killing everything in his sight the sun
rises and some mysterious people appear
finding all the zombies dead somebody
got to them early this woman carefully
approaches denji and sees him transform
back into a human this snake I mean lady
can tell that this kid is something rare
he is a demon hybrid and she offers him
two options denji can come work for her
organization a company that specializes
in Devil hunting or he can die right
here suspicious he asks her if he can
have toes for breakfast and she tells
him that he can have toes jamming
whatever else he'd like and he'll be
well taken care of if he joins her
dengie then Smiles wide and agrees to
wear work for her but only if she
promises he can also play honk High star
rail this free to play RPG from hoyovers
the makers of Genji impact will send you
on this out of this world experience
where you and your senses can embark on
immersive sci-fi Adventures made
acquaintances with captivating
backstories and save the world along the
way this RPG is for everyone to play
anytime and anywhere while enjoying the
star-studded voice cast with four
different languages on the go no problem
honkai star rail is a multi-platform
game that can be played on PC or mobile
so you'll never have to step off the
interstellar train called the astral
Express meet dozens of extraordinary
characters with magnificent outfits and
lifelike Expressions that suit your
unique personal style while you battle
through universe that spans thousands of
years you'll never get bored as a
Trailblazer you can journey through a
Sci-Fi world that's packed with in-game
lore and multiple Side Stories rally and
developed the combat skills of an
intimidating team to battle alongside of
expect orbital Cannon's ice walls
full-fledged armies and much more in
this alluring anime style RPG reach the
end of the universe and you'll be
rewarded with learning the truth about
your self can't wait to join in on the
breathtaking adventure with beautiful
animations and music this RPG promises
the release date has finally been
announced the game is coming April 26th
oh my gosh I'm so excited pre-register
in the link in my description down below
thank you for our sponsor for today's
video Hong Kai star rail okay this is
wild because while we don't know who
this chick is yet we know what she does
she is known as a public safety devil
Hunter basically the legal version of
what we were getting paid to do earlier
by the Yakuza she works for
organizations that deal with devil
hunting at a government level and due to
the threat of devils in this country the
scary ultimatum that this chick gave
denji is not that uncommon because these
people now know that denji is part devil
and now means that he'll be placed on a
watch list best case or end up dying
worst case or even more worst case end
up being a lab rat for the rest of his
days because the government is not going
to let him roam free oh no no no despite
him not having much to lose he needs to
think carefully about the consequences
of what just happened just like the
Yakuza if he doesn't help the government
in some way he's dead if he tries to run
away he's dead too right now if I was
dingy I would agree to work with this
crazy lady but with the goal of learning
everything there is to know about being
a legal devil Hunter so I could become
indispensable to the organization I
would also be on high alert and test the
waters in terms of finding out what the
exact terms of my service are and if I
can provide some minor pushback getting
my way in some areas before they get my
contract down in writing because make no
mistake the government goes after only
the most horrifying devils and they are
far more dangerous than anything we've
ever faced and that means I need some
assurance that I'll be able to get a
deal that benefits me or protects me in
some way against what's to come because
doing anything for an attractive woman
it's a horrible move but it happens to
the best of us and because our devil
secret has already been spotted this
means we have little options other than
to roll with the punches they get in
this girl's car and denji tells her his
story she introduces herself as makima
and tells him that a human merging with
the Devil is incredibly rare she's never
seen a hybrid as perfect as denji he
thinks she's being nice just as she
tells him something mess stop now under
her care she only needs a Yes Man
someone who will do whatever she wants
whenever she wants and he can never say
no she tells denji to say what if he
understands the job and treats him like
a pet he begins to get angry but tries
to calm down just as she politely offers
denji her jacket shocked at someone
finally being nice to him he starts to
feel something weird in his chest and
realizes that he might be falling in
love with this terrifying woman that he
barely knows and that is his biggest
mistake okay we have a serious problem
because at this point it's clear that
denji's little mind is taking him places
that we don't want to go Genji's had it
hard his whole life and now for the
first time in a long while somebody's
nice to him and he's now developed a
freaking Stockholm syndrome in the span
of five minutes this is a big problem
based on how she treated him when she
first saw him she basically said she
wanted a minion A Little Grunt that
would do whatever she wants even
treating dandy like a pet I mean she
told him to say woof this means that she
sees denji as beneath her and this kid
is likely about to get turned into a
human pet yeah nasty and the most
horrifying part about this situation is
one that denji could have benefited the
most from makima here was as calm as a
cucumber when she interacted with denji
despite being a human herself she has no
soul and this means that she likely has
full faith in herself and her abilities
and that means her guard is down because
has no reason to be she's the boss and
she thinks she has all the cards no no
no no because of this I would think she
has a super high ego I would begin to
look at this woman very critically
instead of uh just drooling all over her
like Dungy is because there is a way
that we can turn this around it's clear
that this woman has a great interest in
denji and thinks that he's something
special and we can use her interest in
him to his Advantage remember we're not
trying to seduce her because we want to
we're doing it because our life depends
on it they head to makima's office and
she tells denji that he will now be a
part of an experimental devil hunting
crew and introduces denji to the rest of
his teammates this man named Aki AKA
Samurai Jack wannabe makima tells him
that this guy has been assigned to show
him the ropes but Aki has other plans
taking him out onto the streets Aki
leads denji down this alley and suddenly
beats him to a pulp he tells denji that
he knows that he's got the hots for
makima and that denji doesn't take this
job seriously he tells denji that he
should just quit but denji is determined
to score with this chick so bad and
quickly hits Aki right in the onigiris
Benji tells Aki that he'll do anything
to get some female attention
oh it's so true and that he wants to
have a better life he carries an injured
Aki back to the office and tells makima
that he was attacked by the nut devil
makima laughs it off and tells Aki that
denji is officially joining their
special unit but if he tries to run or
quit he will be killed she tells denji
that he'll be living with Aki from now
on and will work for her until he dies
of old age or dies in line of duty one
or the other the next day Benji starts
his official day at work with Aki and
the two go to their very first case
hitting up this house they head inside
and look for a devil Aki explains to
denji that this devil is known as a
fiend which is when a devil takes
control of a human corpse heading to the
second floor they see the devil fiend
and Aki tells denji to handle it the
devil charges at denji but he simply
chops its head off with his ax and denji
doesn't use his devil Powers confused
Aki tells denji that he should have used
his powers whenever he can't to brutally
Slaughter every devil he sees and make
them scream in horror denji tells Aki
that he prefers to Kill Devils only if
it's quick and painless okay while this
may seem like just another regular day
at the Devil hunting office denji is in
a lot more than he thinks Augie's
more horrifying than any devil that I'm
probably going to meet if I was dingy I
gotta pay attention to this not only did
my partner just tell me to take out this
devil as if I were his personal servant
his personal lap dog but if you notice
Aki told us to use our devil Powers
every chance we get now while that may
seem logical fighting Devil with devil
this move actually makes no sense
because denji told him earlier that he
loses control when he goes full devil
mode and this means that turning into a
devil more frequently will up the
chances that he messes up and if I'm
danji I now know that most of the devil
cases are in the city populated with
millions of people this makes going
after devils and the goal of avoiding
collateral damage even more important
because if denji harms one too many
people in the pursuit of hunting down a
devil wouldn't that then no doubt cause
some problems for him with the
higher-ups in the devil hunting division
killing civilians would also bring about
bad press to makima's division and
remember remember this is the government
that we work for not a private sector
and means that public opinion here is
going to matter in terms of how our
devil hunting branch is perceived by the
general public I'm denji walking a
tightrope between killing as many Devils
as I can and also needing to be very
careful and low-key about how I go about
it and to top it off omakima told us in
that very first day in her office she
said that this unit is an experimental
unit this means that them fighting with
a devil on their side is kind of a newer
thing which makes it all the more reason
that we set a good example and don't
mess this up because all eyes are going
to be honest this is why Aki freaks me
out so much way more than the Devils I'm
going to face because he has an agenda
and will try and get me to mess up and
get myself killed either by Devils or by
the government sooner or later now while
in theory I could try and persuade him
into getting onto my side of things but
from the looks of it it's unlikely that
I'll ever be able to make him come over
to my side anytime soon angry Aki tells
him that he needs to treat devils like
cockroaches he reveals that his whole
family was killed by devils and tells
denji that he needs to get serious about
this job now but the only thing that
denji wants to get serious about is how
to seduce makima and begins planning
right there and then on how to win her
attention later back at demon hunting
headquarters makima tells denji that
he's been assigned a new partner this
girl named power who is a devil themed
makimo tells both these two that they're
still under probation if they don't
produce results soon they will both be
killed so what do they do the two super
powered recruits go on patrol and denji
realizes that this girl is hot and also
batshit crazy power then smells devil
blood and rushes off to chase the scent
chasing after her denji sees this
terrifying sea cucumber devil hungry for
Bloodshed she jumps down and absolutely
crushes this Devil's body laughing like
a total nut job as she does it later
makima arrives at the scene and tells
these two that they've caused too much
attention and they need to be more
subtle with their killing of devils or
else they'll be terminated annoyed the
two afterward go to get a drink power
then asks denji how he can put up with
so much crap from the humans but denji
tells her that he's now living his best
life but the only thing missing for him
is some female attention power that
smiles and offers denji the best
proposal of his entire life she reveals
to him that a certain cat of hers has
been recently stolen by a terrifying
devil bat but if he helps her get her
cat back she'll let him Kappa you know
what denji is shocked but then gets
super happy and he prepares for the most
important mission of his life taking a
bus they soon arrive at this cabin and
power tells denji that the devil bat is
right inside they walk up to it but out
of nowhere denji senses that something
is wrong and tries to react but Power
quickly knocks him out and drags him
inside the house inside he is shocked
and sees power's Cat is being held
hostage but realizes that he is not here
to save anyone but to be currency for
power and to be this Devil's next meal
and the monster prepares to eat him man
this is just like deja vu all over again
denji here yet again thinking with his
uh if you know what I mean because power
basically tricked the crap out of Dungy
into saving her cat and then sacrificed
him to the devil bat nice she tricked
him and baited him by taking taking
advantage of the one human trait that
people greatly underestimate according
to the basics of psychology and human
nature humans are naturally stubborn and
will rarely do what you ask however if
the most effective way to bypass their
natural resistance is to hit their weak
point a part of themselves that they
have the least control over which is
their desire for pleasure most people in
the world go through an average life and
that's why this crap works so well for
manipulation tenji wanted something that
was out of the ordinary of his horrible
life something new and exciting and
wanted to get some Nom Noms power took
advantage of denji's ultimate desire and
led them along like a Fish Hook Line and
Sinker but the thing is denji could have
spotted four signs that suggested the
power was full of crap right from the
beginning what if I'm denji I'm
suspicious of power because she would
have known what we were just like her
alone with no one to turn to she would
have known that we would probably
believe her story since we don't have
anyone else to give us a second opinion
and even before we left to go save her
cat we had to check her out of the
office like she wrote library book and
this I would think would give us a
pretty early indication of how
unpredictable and volatile she really is
because remember back in the bus if we
noticed during that time period power's
attitude and Body Language subtly
changed she went from being very worked
up and emotional in the beginning to all
of a sudden having a very Stern face
with a very relaxed body language
because while at this point there's no
guarantee we would save her cat but why
would she change her body language so
suddenly powerstory was likely real but
there's something else going on that she
wasn't telling us because oftentimes the
best lies are the ones rooted in truth
the bad devil picks denji up and takes a
bite out of him but that's when he
realizes that denji is not a pure human
angry he takes Powers cat and eats her
cat right in front of power shocked and
surprisingly just from a cat the bat
tells her that it now has enough energy
to go and kill the rest of the city man
how much protein was in that cat anyways
It prepares to fly away but Dungey
quickly jumps up and grabs onto its legs
quickly turning into chainsaw man he
slices the bat's Wings right off of him
causing the both of them to fall from
the sky and onto the city street denji
quickly charges at this monster and he
manages to critically injure the devil
and cuts through its guts he saves power
and her cat and she asks him why he
tried to save her and he points to his
mission objective to Kappa you know what
power rolls her eyes but agrees to let
Dungy get his reward and he gets ready
for the greatest day of his life but
suddenly his pervy hand gets chopped off
and he freaks out and sees his bloody
hand get picked up by another monster
it's the leech devil Genji quickly
protects power and tries to turn into
chainsaw man but that's when he realizes
that he can't complete his
transformation he's out of gas he's lost
too much blood the leech devil reveals
that the bad devil was her boyfriend and
now they all must die okay all these
tentacles and things are starting to
make me think that this anime is turning
into one of those other types of animes
if you know what I mean this creature is
known as the leech devil the scary thing
about this is that its tongue has the
ability to pierce through bodies if his
tongue can do that I can't imagine what
the rest of its limbs could do I would
imagine it would royally fudge up denji
even more so at this point he's lost one
of his hands and due to the blood loss
means he can can't change into his devil
form limb lost from this area
specifically means that significant
arteries like the radial and ulnar
arteries have been severed and in a
normal human being could cause someone
to bleed out within 5-10 minutes this
could help explain why such a a small
injury could cause denji to run out of
blood so quickly but while the situation
may seem hopeless for our hero there are
a few things that he could have done
better if I was him I would one look to
the two perfect living blood bags that
we have sitting behind us because one
can't move and the other one is a cat in
a cage I mean come on it's like taking
candy from a baby and who even does that
being the Devils that we are it means
that it's entirely possible that we
could supplement our own blood loss by
taking a cheeky little bite out of power
herself and maybe even take a bite out
of the cat if we're feeling frisky
enough it's noted that when the bad
devil took a bite out of denji it
commented on how disgusting denji tasted
this means that probably devil blood is
not as tasty as pineapple and pizza if
we really wanted to use our backup blood
supply by fueling up and regaining all
of our powers in this situation is
important as this leech devil didn't
really show up by by accident but out of
anger and wanting Revenge yeah that's
right this leech devil was the bad
Devil's boo-boo and now he's out to kill
us as payback we need all the power we
can because this leech is pissed Genji
quickly Dodges her strikes and tries to
fight back but is hopeless he's too weak
he tries to scale up her body and charge
through the smoke jumping in the air and
he attacks her from above getting
stabbed through the stomach the leech
devil prepares to eat him when ake
arrives at the scene how convenient with
a trick up his sleep he calls upon the
fox devil and it instantly kills the
leech devil look at that thing it's
awesome later denji wakes up in the
hospital he's had his arm reattached
thanks to his devil Powers suspicious of
awk he asks him if he's a devil hybrid
as well but Aki tells him that devil
Hunter sometimes make contracts with
other Devils and this contract allows
them to use a devil's power in exchange
for something of theirs that causes them
pain like trading an eye for a devil's
power or a piece of Flesh Aki then asks
denji how they ran into the bad devil
and thinks that power was up to some
funny business okay while this situation
may not seem like a big deal right now
Daniel is at a point where he could
screw a friend over or gain a very
important Ally which could help him out
big time the truth is if I was denji I
did get set up by power she did it out
of desperation to be fair for a cat
meaning that there's still a chance that
I could trust her if I helped her out
this time because then she would owe me
one and by Saving her ass right now
would really put me on good terms with
her so maybe I would present Aki with
one of two responses as to what just
happened out in the field one I would
tell him a rough overview of what
happened that is rooted in truth
highlighting certain truths while
leaving out certain to moments I could
tell him that we were out hunting demons
on supervised and that's when power
caught the son of a demon which we
followed and discovered that it was
holding a random cat hostage I know
weird right but power being a huge fan
of cats at this point freaked out and
tried to save the cat and me hating bats
because nasty I hate bats with all of my
being so I also join in on the fight but
that's when the bat hit the cat and
went South and we ended up having to
chase it down and that's when the worm
came over and then yada yada and yeah I
would then throw off any suspicions that
Aki might have the non-protecting power
by making fun of her cat addiction and
by Ash asking Aki why he set me up with
such an unstable weirdo by phrasing the
story of what happened in this way we
could highlight the fact that we did
technically Break The Rules by going out
to demon hunt without permission and got
screwed as a result but we could keep
the true origin of why we were there in
the first place under wraps because if
anyone finds out that power was
basically working with the demon behind
our backs I'm pretty sure she would get
uh fired though more likely killed and
we might even get dragged along as well
which is definitely not the plan for me
denji tells Aki that he doesn't know how
they ran into the bad devil starting to
like him Aki lets denji off the hook
only if he promises to listen to his
orders from now on right and denji
agrees heading back to HQ Aki makes a
report to makima about the day's events
and she begins to suspect that Aki has
gone soft on denji but Aki Shrugged it
off the next day denji and Aki
discovered the most horrifying news and
find out that power has been sent to
live with them it's a nightmare and Aki
gets a call from makima telling him that
keeping an eye on power 24 7 and Genji
will benefit everyone long term right
later in the day denji tries to clean
the toilet when power shows up and he's
annoyed and asks her what does she want
but that's when she tells him that it's
now time to complete his mission
objective wink wink and denji begins to
sweat a little bit danger does the thing
and has the time of his life and has now
changed man and now with one of his live
submissions now complete he begins to
get a little bit sad and heads into the
office the next day to meet makima she
asks him what's wrong and he tells her
that he's finally achieved one of his
goals last night but the reward wasn't
as epic as he thought it'd be bummer
makima suddenly grabs denji's hat and
tells him that the experience will be
better if denji has fun with someone
that he truly likes instead things get a
little weird and dingy oddly enough
likes it a lot and is stuck in her
trance and that's when she asks denji
for a favor and she tells him that she
wants him to defeat the gun devil
terrifying monster that has the power to
kill millions of people in minutes she
shows him pieces of the gun devil in
this box stray bullets left behind at
different crime scenes by the gun devil
she tells him that these bullets vibrate
when they are in close practice
proximity to the gun devil or one of his
other bullets the more bullets they
connect the closer they'll be to finding
this terrifying devil Dungey gets a
little nervous but she tells him that
she thinks he has what it takes and
makes him an offer that he can't refuse
a hint wink wink if he completes this
Mission as a reward she'll do whatever
that she wants he gets super excited and
tells her that he's been preparing for
this day his entire really short life
later they get a call that an eyewitness
has spotted a devil in a nearby hotel
but the eyewitnesses have now gone
missing suspicious Genji's crew rushes
over to the devil location carrying with
them the bullets from the gun devil and
they start to vibrate near this hotel
and Aki thinks their mission is in there
but this spiky hair guide still doesn't
trust denji and demands that he leaves
the group and Aki tells him that they
need his powers because whatever devil
is in this hotel is extremely powerful
eye patch girl here then tries to calm
everyone down by announcing that whoever
kills this devil will get a French kiss
from her and that's when denji charges
in motivated as hell because why
wouldn't he be and that was his biggest
mistake entering in the building they
investigate this Corridor but suddenly
this door opens up and a small devil
that appears and tries to attack them
but it easily gets slaughtered spiky
hair guy thinks that this Mission will
now be a piece of cake but he has no
idea how wrong he is the group then
heads up to the eighth floor but that's
when they realize that they've already
been here before concerned they try to
assess the situation but it doesn't look
good all the floors lead to the eighth
floor and all the rooms and windows
don't lead outside the gang realizes
that they've now become stuck in some
sort of Frozen time Loop or another
dimension in some of the weaker members
begin to freak out and Aki tries to calm
them down hours pass but no one is able
to find a way out and everyone begins to
get a little bit desperate Augie reports
back to the group with bad news and
tells them that the devil they killed
earlier has now grown into something
horrifying the group rushes out to see
it for themselves shocked they've never
seen a devil like this before and with
no way out this devil tells the group
that it will let them out of this
nightmare for a price it wants denji and
asks this group to hand him over so it
can kill denji right where he stands
because it wants to feed on his blood it
needs to feed on his blood the group
stands still in horror but right behind
denji Adora quietly opens up this girl
will call her hair clip girl comes out
holding a knife she's at her breaking
point and apologizes to denji suddenly
she charges at him and Aki deflects her
knife and she gets knocked out Aki
realizes that he can't call on his Fox
devil so eyepatch girl uses her ghost
powers to harm this devil but that was
her biggest mistake suddenly this
monster cries out in pain and begins to
grow in size forcing them to back up and
the group freaks out and realizes that
they're running out of hallway the devil
tells them that no matter how much they
harm it its heart its weak point is not
on this floor okay these guys are
probably in the worst situation they'll
ever be in and what they're up against
is no joke this ugly bastard is known as
The Eternity devil it has the power to
turn any area of reality into looped
sections of three-dimensional space
making any Escape impossible and this
area basically becomes part of the
devil's stomach and within its stomach
it can do basically anything it wants
including freezing time and create
creating evil monsters that can torment
and kill anyone trapped within but while
this devil is not to be messed with
these devil Hunters really have no one
to blame but themselves because they
came in unprepared as hell it's
mentioned that eyewitnesses who reported
about this devil in the first place went
missing that should have been their
first clue that something fishy is going
on cause yeah no kidding sense without
the eyewitness present there was no way
for the devil Hunters to be able to
confirm this story now while this could
have been seen as simple bait to lure
the devil Hunters into this hotel and on
top of that the guests in the hotel were
reported to be unaccounted for as well
if I were these Hunters I would have
first tried to do a little bit more
preparation before going in I mean it's
not that hard to check out at least the
outside of the building a little bit
more I would have tried at the very
least to assess what kind of danger
we're heading into because these guys
certainly didn't do it's the late
90s which means that the use of security
cameras have already existed meaning
that average establishments or
businesses like a hotel definitely would
have had some the group should have used
this Tech first to get a timeline of
what the hell went wrong and when they
didn't even bother to check if this
place had cameras in the first place and
remember this isn't just just a bunch of
police entering a dangerous situation
this is world full of devils and magical
powers and crazy that makes
absolutely no sense the final factor
that could have given them a clue as to
what they were up against was the
reoccurring appearance of the number
eight I mean check it out look at this
they were trapped on the eighth floor
and saw the Frozen time as being stuck
at 8 18. the visual similarity of 8 to
the infinity symbol could have clued
them in as to what they were about to
face was The Eternity death but
fortunately the one advantage they still
have up their sleeve as long as they
don't kill off denji is denji himself
because this devil hasn't tried to kill
him yet it wants them to hand him over
to it this means that like I said this
devil really fears denji for some reason
and doesn't want to get into a fair
fight against him at all and that is
something that they should have keyed in
on and something that they could use
spiky hair guy here then gets convinced
that they must kill denji but Aki and
eye patch girl refuse and then the hours
passed by and things begin to wear on
them a little bit an eyepatch go begins
to change her mind Justin hair clip girl
begins to freak out again and starts to
go crazy her fear causes the devil to
get stronger and grow even faster
forcing the group to run for the final
time hungrier than ever the devil flips
the hallway and now has this group dead
to right everybody is now desperate and
then eyepatch girl uses her ghost hand
to trap Aki and the rest of the group
pins denji down and prepares to kill him
and hair clip girl charges at him but
Aki manages to save Genji's life getting
stabbed this shocks the whole group and
Aki tells everyone that they'll need
denji's help to kill the gun devil the
world's most horrifying devil and it's
only a matter of time before they find
it they need to Dengue and denji finally
realizes that he has something to do and
offers to sacrifice himself to this
devil but not without taking it down
with him he tells eye patch girl that he
owes her that kiss if he makes the doll
alive and he looks down at the darkness
and the horror beneath him he pulls his
chest string and prepares to turn into
chainsaw man jumping off into the empty
bowels of this Devil's body but what do
you guys think about the video let us
know what you like about it and what you
didn't like about it don't forget to
like subscribe leave a comment down
below and as always don't forget to
check out our how to be playlist